la situación en Brasil en esos momentos
es caótica manifestantes bolsonaristas
han invadido los principales edificios
oficiales de la capital El Congreso
Nacional la Corte Suprema y el palacio
del plan alto con piedras y con palos de
madera han causado muchos destrozos
dentro y fuera de esos edificios En
cuanto la policía intenta reprimir a los
manifestantes y la prensa nacional ya
los tilda de terroristas recordamos que
hoy se cumplen un dos años y dos días de
la invasión del capital de los Estados
Unidos y se piensa que estos actos estén
inspirados en los movimientos que en
aquel momento estaban contestando La
derrota de Donald Trump bolsonaro que
está en los Estados Unidos en Orlando en
estos momentos no se ha pronunciado pero
la situación puede tener una escalada de
violencia y una noticia de contrapunto
aquí en Río de Janeiro en estos momentos
se celebra la apertura Carnaval no
oficial y hay una muchedumbre de
personas alegres disfrazadas en las
calles que crean un contraste muy
estridente con lo que está pasando en
estos momentos en Brasilia